it's sick what's happening and there's
there's no jury in this case it is a
Democrat activist judge who's who's
smiling in the camera who's a
Democrat it's a complete show and
you know we can't let this we can't let
this stand well I think there's no jury
intentionally I think Trump doesn't want
a jury a New York jury is just going to
rule against you it's a waste of time
it's a the Trump team probably knows if
they went for jury trial they'd end up
losing either way but this time it would
actually cost them you know $30 million
in in a legal battle their attitude
probably right now is the judge has has
actually done Trump a favor with the
summary judgment because now Trump is
going to appeal he's been planning to
appeal he needs to get it outside of you
know of of New York City basically and
that's where his actual chance of
winning is going to be don't waste time
and money with a jury trial let the
judge say what he says and then you can
appeal and the judge made the mistake of
being a